This spring my friend, Etgar, was visiting the United States. He's Israeli. And we went to the Museum of Modern Art in New York City to see this exhibit by this artist named Cindy Sherman. And this very strange thing happened that we didn't know what to make of it. It was truly a mystery. And I invited Etgar here onto the radio show to talk about it. We recorded this conversation a few days ago when I was still getting over a cold. So you'll hear that my voice is a little croaky in this recording.
今年春天，我的朋友埃特加（Etgar）来美国访问。他是以色列人。我们去了纽约市现代艺术博物馆，参观一位名叫辛迪·舍曼（Cindy Sherman）的艺术家的展览。发生了一件非常奇怪的事，我们不知道该怎么理解。这真是一个谜。我邀请埃特加来电台谈谈这件事。我们几天前录下了这段对话，当时我还没从感冒中恢复过来。所以在这段录音中，你会听到我的声音有点沙哑。
So I've been thinking about how to describe the exhibit. Do you want to describe it?
我一直在想该怎么描述这个展览。你想描述一下吗？
No, no. I think you will describe it better.
不，不。我想你描述得会更好。
OK. Well, basically, Cindy Sherman-- she photographs herself as hundreds of different people. And to say that-- if you haven't seen these pictures, just to get it across, she's utterly and completely transformed in them. And some of them-- they look like old movie stills. And some on them-- they look like Renaissance paintings. And some of them are super bright garish colors. And in some she's beautiful. And in some she's grotesque. And in some she's this composed matronly lady. And the way I remember the story is that you and I were walking into the third room of this exhibit. So we had seen two rooms of these things.
好吧。基本上，辛迪·舍曼——她把自己拍成数百个不同的人。如果还没看过这些照片，为了让你明白，她在照片中彻底地、完全地变了身。其中一些看起来像老电影剧照。有些看起来像文艺复兴时期的油画。还有一些是色彩极其鲜艳刺眼的。有些照片里她很美。有些照片里她很怪诞。还有些照片里她是位端庄的贵妇。我记得的故事是，当时你和我正走进展览的第三个展厅。所以我们已经看过两个展厅的作品了。
I think that it was about the time when I realized that it was her in all the photos. Because before that I thought it was different people.
我想那大概是我意识到所有照片里都是她本人的时候。因为在此之前，我以为那是不同的人。
Right, right. And then you said, oh wait. It's all the same person? And then a woman came over to us.
对，对。然后你说，噢等等。这全是同一个人？然后一个女人朝我们走过来。
And she said that she is Cindy Sherman.
她说她就是辛迪·舍曼。
Yeah. And--
对。而且——
And that she comes to the exhibit every day to see how people react to it.
她说她每天都来展览看人们的反应。
And so she-- if I had to describe her, I'd say that she looked like she was about 55 or 60, wire rim glasses, gray hair.
所以，如果我必须描述她，我会说她看起来大约 55 或 60 岁，戴着细框眼镜，灰白头发。
Yes. She looked to me like a pretty well educated upper middle class lady who likes books.
是的。在我看来，她像是一位受过良好教育、喜欢读书的中产阶级上层女性。
Yeah. Looking at her, thinking that she might be Cindy Sherman, I thought if you were to try to put on a costume to exactly blend in with the crowd at the Museum of Modern Art, this is the costume.
是的。看着她，心想她可能是辛迪·舍曼，我当时想，如果你要化妆来完美地融入现代艺术博物馆的人群，这就是最好的装扮。
But the thing about it is that when you see the Cindy Sherman photos, you will realize that she can look as old or as young or as beautiful or as ugly as she wants. So I just, as I spoke to her, I looked at the photos around me. And the range of appearance that were in them kind of-- I said, OK, this woman could be one of those photos.
但问题是，当你看到辛迪·舍曼的照片时，你会意识到她可以看起来随心所欲地老、年轻、美丽或丑陋。所以，当我和她说话时，我看着周围的照片。照片中展现的外貌范围让我觉得——我说，好吧，这个女人可能是那些照片中的一张。
And I remember-- like I did the same thing. I was looking at the pictures on the wall. And I was looking at her face. And I was trying to think, could this be her face. And I was just trying to get her to stay there and keep talking to us so I could figure this out. Were you also trying to keep her there talking to us? Was that your experience of it too?
我记得——我也是这么做的。我看着墙上的照片。我看着她的脸。我试着想，这会是她的脸吗。我只是想让她留在那儿继续跟我们说话，这样我才能弄清楚。你当时也在试图留住她跟我们说话吗？这也是你的感受吗？
No. My experience was that oh, Ira is so excited. And kind of thinking maybe I'm missing something. Or maybe Ira is gone crazy. But I never saw you so excited.
不。我的感受是，噢，艾拉（Ira）太兴奋了。心想也许我错过了什么。或者也许艾拉疯了。但我从没见你这么兴奋过。
You never saw me so excited?
你从没见我这么兴奋过？
No, no. Maybe this says something about our relationship. Maybe you are always excited. But just went I'm around, you become this kind of cold fish.
没有，没有。也许这说明了我们的关系。也许你一直都很兴奋。但只要我一在场，你就变得像条冷鱼一样。
I'm a really good friend. Yeah. And so I guess that I noticed that she was getting a little bit put off by my interest. And then she said to us, oh, I'm not really Cindy Sherman. And I took that as oh, she is Cindy Sherman. But she has to end this conversation. That's it. She's had enough of me. And did you take it as she's not Cindy Sherman? Or did you just think she was trying to get away from us?
我是个很好的朋友。是的。我想我注意到她对我的兴趣感到有点不快了。然后她对我们说，噢，我其实不是辛迪·舍曼。我把它理解为，噢，她就是辛迪·舍曼。但她必须结束这段对话。就这样。她已经受够我了。你是认为她不是辛迪·舍曼吗？还是你觉得她只是想摆脱我们？
No. Later I thought to myself that if I would pretend to be Cindy Sherman, the last thing I would do would be to tell people I'm not Cindy Sherman. I would be too embarrassed to say in the end I'm not Cindy Sherman. So I kind of thought in the end, like after she had left, that she probably was Cindy Sherman.
不。后来我想，如果我要假装是辛迪·舍曼，我最不会做的事就是告诉别人我不是辛迪·舍曼。如果最后说我不是辛迪·舍曼，我会觉得太尴尬了。所以最后，在离开后，我觉得她很可能就是辛迪·舍曼。
I agree. To me it made her very credibly Cindy Sherman.
我同意。对我来说，这让她看起来非常像辛迪·舍曼。
Yeah. And it was also like be about the nature of the exhibit. Because she's a woman with 100 personas coming with her 101 persona. And I would say that even if she wasn't, I think it would be smart of the museum to hire women who would go around and say that they are Cindy Sherman.
是的。这也像是展览本质的一部分。因为她是一个拥有 100 个人格的女人，带着她的第 101 个人格来了。我会说，即使她不是，我认为博物馆雇佣那些到处说自己是辛迪·舍曼的女性也是很聪明的做法。
I thought about this for weeks after it happened. And I really did not know what to think. You know if it wasn't Cindy Sherman, if it was not her in a way, the whole thing is even better. If there is some Upper East Side 55, 60-year-old lady who just walks up to people in the Museum of Modern Art and claims to be Cindy Sherman, I love that lady. I love the balls on that lady. That is somebody embracing life. For Etgar, when we talked about this on tape, he surprised me by insisting that it is better not to now. He said it is a better experience to just never find out the truth.
事发后我思考了几个星期。我真的不知道该怎么想。你知道，如果那不是辛迪·舍曼，如果那不是她，某种程度上，整件事反而更好。如果有一位上东区 55、60 岁的女士，只是走到现代艺术博物馆的人群中自称是辛迪·舍曼，我喜欢这位女士。我喜欢这位女士的胆识。那才是拥抱生活的人。对于埃特加，当我们录音谈论这件事时，他坚持说最好不要知道真相，这让我很惊讶。他说，永远不知道真相其实是更好的体验。
Look. I can walk you through all the scenarios, OK? A, she is Cindy Sherman. She says I'm Cindy Sherman. You say hey, Etgar, can you take a photo in your iPhone of me with Cindy Sherman? This is the one experience. The second experience-- she says, I'm not Cindy Sherman. I'm just a bored woman who's into harassing people in exhibit. We say to her go away, woman. And we throw things at her. And she goes away. Or c, she says I'm Cindy Sherman. No, I'm not Cindy Sherman. And we still contemplate about that. I think that from the three options, this is the most interesting and exciting one. And we got our money worth. You know, we went. We saw a show. We met a woman. She said she's Cindy Sherman. She said she wasn't Cindy Sherman. We still don't know if she is or she isn't. I mean I wish all exhibitions were like that.
听着。我可以帮你梳理所有场景，好吗？A，她是辛迪·舍曼。她说我是辛迪·舍曼。你说嘿，埃特加，能用你的 iPhone 给我和辛迪·舍曼拍张照吗？这是一种体验。第二种体验——她说，我不是辛迪·舍曼。我只是个喜欢在展览里骚扰人的无聊女人。我们对她说走开，女人。我们向她扔东西。然后她离开了。或者 C，她说我是辛迪·舍曼。不，我不是辛迪·舍曼。然后我们还在思考那个问题。我认为在这三种选择中，这是最有趣、最令人兴奋的一个。我们的票价没白花。你知道，我们去了。我们看了展览。我们见了一个女人。她说她是辛迪·舍曼。她说她不是辛迪·舍曼。我们仍然不知道她是不是。我的意思是，我希望所有的展览都像这样。
I'm going to get Cindy Sherman. I've set up a phone call to speak with Cindy Sherman about this.
我要去找辛迪·舍曼。我已经安排了一个电话，要和辛迪·舍曼谈谈这件事。
Leave poor Cindy alone. Why do you want to put her in that spot? I think it's not going to clarify anything.
放过可怜的辛迪吧。你为什么要把她置于那种境地？我觉得这不会澄清任何事情。
Because you're saying that she might lie either way.
因为你说她无论如何都可能在撒谎。
Because I'm saying if it was Cindy Sherman, then she had already lied. And if it wasn't Cindy Sherman, then Cindy Sherman could still lie.
因为我说如果那是辛迪·舍曼，那她已经撒谎了。如果那不是辛迪·舍曼，辛迪·舍曼仍然可能撒谎。
Hello.
喂。
Hey. Is this Cindy Sherman?
嘿。是辛迪·舍曼吗？
Yes.
是。
Cindy, it's Ira Glass.
辛迪，我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Hi. I'm so sorry about yesterday. I feel like I'm always--
嗨。对于昨天的事我深表歉意。我觉得我总是——
I reached Cindy Sherman this week. She's saying she's sorry right there. Because she accidentally forgot our phone appointment on Tuesday. And I'm only playing you that part of the recording to give you a sense of what an utterly normal, straightforward, undeceptive person she seemed like on the telephone. And I told her the whole story of the woman who walked up to me and Etgar at the Museum of Modern Art.
这周我联系上了辛迪·舍曼。她就在那儿道歉。因为她不小心忘记了我们周二的电话预约。我播放录音的这一部分只是为了让你感觉到她在电话里看起来是一个多么完全正常、直率、不欺骗的人。我告诉了她那个在现代艺术博物馆向我和埃特加走来的女人的整个故事。
Wow.
哇。
So was that you?
所以那是你吗？
Not at all. Oh my god. But I'd love to know who she is or-- I mean-- if this person really comes every day. Or I mean I've just vaguely fantasized about being in the exhibit while the public's there. But then what always sort of complete turned me off of it is any particular moment that somebody would suddenly realize it was me-- that would just freak me out.
根本不是。噢，我的天哪。但我很想知道她是谁，或者——我的意思是——如果这个人真的每天都来。或者我的意思是，我只是模糊地幻想过在公众参观时身处展览现场。但后来总是让我感到彻底打消念头的是，某人突然意识到是我——那会让我惊慌失措。
Do you like the idea that she did this?
你喜欢她这样做这个点子吗？
Yeah. I think it's great. I wonder-- I really do wonder if she does it a lot or if it was just some, like, fluke thing where she just thought oh, I'm going to play with this guy. Maybe once you air this, other people will have other--
是的。我觉得这很棒。我好奇——我真的很想知道她是经常这样做，还是这只是一次侥幸，她只是想噢，我要捉弄一下这个家伙。也许一旦你播出了这个节目，其他人会有其他的——
Sightings.
发现。
Yeah, right.
是的，没错。
That didn't even occur to me. Right, yeah. Let me just say, like, if you're hearing this interview and this has happened to you, please go to our website and be in touch.
我甚至没想过这一点。对，是的。让我说，如果你听到了这次采访，并且这事也发生在你身上，请访问我们的网站并联系我们。
That would be so interesting.
那会非常有趣。
OK. So she is not part of the show.
好的。所以她不是展览的一部分。
No.
不是。
You did not hire her, put her up to it?
你没雇佣她，没指使她这样做？
No, no.
没有，没有。
Do you have a message for this lady if we find her?
如果我们找到这位女士，你有什么话要带给她吗？
No.
没有。
OK.
好的。
I mean she should do it more often. Yeah. What would be funny is if more people were going around, pretending.
我的意思是，她应该多做几次。是的。更有趣的是，如果有更多的人到处假装。
Potential fake Cindy Sherman's and victims of fake Cindy Sherman's, please note. The exhibit moves to San Francisco in July. Well today on our program, Switcharoo, pretending to be somebody or something you are not. Sometimes that's perfectly fine, perfectly innocent, hurts no one. Sometimes it is not that at all. And sometimes it is really hard to tell. From WBEX Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
潜在的假辛迪·舍曼们以及假辛迪·舍曼的受害者们，请注意。展览将于七月移至旧金山。好了，今天我们的节目是《移花接木》，假装成一个你不是的人或东西。有时这完全没问题，完全无害，不伤害任何人。有时则完全不是那样。而且有时真的很难分辨。来自芝加哥 WBEX，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Healthy Start. So my friend, Etgar, is somebody whose work is actually here on the radio show from time to time. That's how I got to know him. Etgar Keret is his name. He writes short fiction here in the program. And he's thought a lot about this subject, about the pleasure of pretending to be someone else. And he has this short story. It's read for us by an actor. Because Etgar always prefers that somebody read his stories on the radio show whose English is easier to understand. Here it is.
第一幕，《健康的开始》。我的朋友埃特加是一个他的作品偶尔会出现在这个广播节目中的人。我就是这样认识他的。埃特加·克雷特（Etgar Keret）是他的名字。他为这个节目撰写短篇小说。他深入思考过这个主题，关于假装成别人的乐趣。他有这个短篇故事。由一位演员为我们朗读。因为埃特加总是更喜欢让英语更容易听懂的人在广播节目中读他的故事。这就是它。
Every night in the months after she had left him, he'd fall asleep in a different spot-- on the sofa, in an armchair in the living room, on the mat in the balcony like some homeless bum. Every morning he made a point of going out for breakfast. Even prisoners get a daily walk in the yard, don't they? At the cafe, they always gave him a table set for two and sat him across from an empty chair-- always, even when the waiter specifically asked him if he was alone.
在她离开他的那几个月里，他每天晚上都在不同的地方入睡——沙发上、客厅的扶手椅上、阳台的垫子上，就像个无家可归的流浪汉。每天早上，他都特意出去吃早餐。囚犯每天都有机会在院子里散步，不是吗？在咖啡馆，他们总是给他一张双人桌，让他坐在空椅子对面——总是这样，即使服务员明确问他是否是一个人。
Other people would be sitting there in twos or threes, laughing, or tasting each others food, or fighting over the check, while Myron sat by himself eating his healthy start-- orange juice, muesli with honey, decaf double espresso with warm low fat milk on the side. Of course it would have been nicer if someone were sitting down across from him and laughing with him, if there had been someone to argue with over the check. And he'd have had to struggle to hand the money to the waitress, saying don't take it from him. Avery, put it back. This one's on me. But he didn't really have anyone to do that with. And breakfast alone was 100 times better than staying home.
其他人会两三个人坐在一起，笑着，尝尝对方的食物，或者为账单争执，而迈伦（Myron）则独自坐着吃他健康的早餐——橙汁、蜂蜜麦片、脱咖啡因双倍浓缩咖啡，旁边还有温热的脱脂牛奶。当然，如果有人坐在他对面和他一起笑，如果有人能和他争论账单，那会更好。他不得不努力把钱递给服务员，说别从他那里拿。艾弗里，放回去。这顿我请。但他真的没有可以那样做的人。独自吃早餐也比待在家里强 100 倍。
Myron spend a lot of time eying the other tables. He'd eavesdrop on conversations, read the sports supplement, or examine the ups and downs of the Israeli shares on Wall Street with an air of detached concern. Sometimes someone would come over and ask for a section of the paper he'd finished reading. And he would nod and try to smile. Once when a sexy young mother with a baby and a stroller walked over to him, he even said to her as he gave up the front page with the banner headline about a gang rape in the suburbs, what a crazy world we're bringing our children into. He thought it sounds like a kind of statement that brings people closer together, pointing as it did to their common fate. But the sexy mom just glared at him and took the Healthy Living supplement too without asking.
迈伦花了很多时间观察其他桌子。他会偷听对话，看体育副刊，或者带着超然的关切审视华尔街以色列股票的涨跌。有时有人会走过来要一份他看完的报纸。他会点头并试着微笑。有一次，当一位带着婴儿和婴儿车的性感年轻妈妈走过来时，他在交出头版上关于郊区轮奸案的横幅标题时甚至对她说，我们正把孩子带进一个多么疯狂的世界啊。他认为这听起来像是一种能拉近人与人之间距离的陈述，因为它指出了他们共同的命运。但那位性感的妈妈只是怒视着他，连问都没问就把《健康生活》副刊也拿走了。
Then one Thursday, a fat sweaty guy walked into the cafe and smiled at him. Myron was caught off guard. The last person who'd given him a smile was Maian just before she had left him five months earlier. And her smile had been unmistakably sarcastic. Whereas this one was soft, almost apologetic. The fat guy gestured something, apparently a signal that he'd like to sit down. And Myron nodded almost without thinking. The fat guy took a seat.
然后在一个周四，一个胖乎乎、满头大汗的家伙走进咖啡馆，对他笑了笑。迈伦措手不及。上一个对他微笑的人是玛雅（Maian），在他离开他五个月前。她的笑容有着明显的讽刺意味。而这个人的笑容却很柔和，甚至带着歉意。胖家伙做了一个手势，显然是想坐下的信号。迈伦几乎没多想就点了点头。胖家伙坐了下来。
Rube, he said. Listen, I'm really sorry I'm late. I know we said 10. But I had a nightmare morning with the kid. It crossed Myron's mind that maybe he ought to tell the fat guy he wasn't Ruben. But he found himself checking his watch instead and saying what's 10 minutes? Forget it. Then neither of them spoke for a second. And Myron asked if the kid was OK.
鲁本（Rube），他说。听着，我很抱歉我迟到了。我知道我们说好 10 点的。但我早上被孩子搞得一团糟。迈伦脑子里闪过一个念头，也许他应该告诉这个胖子他不是鲁本。但他发现自己反而看了看手表说，10 分钟算什么？忘了它吧。然后两人沉默了一秒。迈伦问孩子还好吗。
And the fat guy said she was. It was just said she'd started a new kindergarten. And every time he took are there, she had a hard time letting him go. But never mind. He stopped short. You've got enough on your plate without my problems. Let's get down to business. Myron took a deep breath and waited. Look, the fat guy said. 500's too high. Give it to me for 400. Know what? 410 even. And I'm good for 600 pieces. 480, Myron said. And that's only if you're good for 1,000.
胖子说她很好。只是说她刚上了新幼儿园。每次他送她去那儿，她都很难让他离开。但没关系。他话没说完就停住了。你已经够忙了，没必要再听我的烦心事。让我们谈谈正事吧。迈伦深吸一口气，等着。看，胖子说。500 太高了。400 给我吧。知道吗？甚至 410。我保证 600 件货。480，迈伦说。那得是你保证 1,000 件货才行。
You got to understand, the fat guy said. The market's in the crapper, what with the recession and all. Just last night on the news they showed people eating out of garbage cans. If you keep pushing, I'll have to sell high. You're pricing me right out of the market. Don't worry, Myron told him. For every three people eating out of garbage cans, there's someone driving a Mercedes. This made the fat guy laugh out loud. They told me you were tough, he muttered with a smile. I'm just like you, Myron protested, simply trying to keep body and soul together.
你得明白，胖子说。市场现在很糟糕，经济衰退什么的。就在昨晚的新闻里，他们还播了人们在垃圾桶里找吃的。如果你继续逼我，我就得高价卖了。你这是要把我挤出市场。别担心，迈伦告诉他。每有三个人吃垃圾桶里的食物，就有一个人开着奔驰。这让胖子大笑起来。他们告诉我你很难对付，他笑着嘀咕道。我跟你一样，迈伦抗议道，只是试图维持生计。
The fat guy wiped his sweaty palm on his shirt and then held it out. 460, he said. 460 and I take 1,000. When he saw Myron wasn't reacting, he added 460, 1,000 pieces. And I owe you a favor. And you know better than anyone, Ruben, that in our business favors are worth more than money. This last sentence was all Myron needed to take the outstretched hand and shake it. For the first time in his life someone told him a favor, someone who thought his name was Rubin, but still. And when they had finished eating, as they argued over who would pick up the tab, a warm feeling spread through Myron's stomach. He beat the fat guy to it by 1/10 of a second and shoved the crumpled bill into the waitresses hand.
胖子在衬衫上擦了擦汗湿的手掌，然后伸了出来。460，他说。460，我要 1,000 件。看到迈伦没反应，他补充道，460，1,000 件。我还欠你一个人情。而且你比任何人都清楚，鲁本，在我们的生意里，人情比钱值钱。最后一句话让迈伦握住了那只伸过来的手。这是他一生中第一次有人告诉他一个人情，一个以为他叫鲁本的人，但仍然。当他们吃完饭，当他们争论谁来结账时，一种温暖的感觉在迈伦的胃里散开。他比胖子快了 0.1 秒，把皱巴巴的钞票塞进服务员手里。
From that day on it became practically a standard procedure. Myron would take a seat, give his order, and keep a lookout for any new person who came into the cafe. And if that person started searching the tables with an expectant look, Myron would quickly wave and invite him or her to take a seat. I don't want this to end up in court, a bald guy with thick eyebrows told him. Me neither, Myron conceded. It's always better to settle things amicably. Just remember, I don't do night shifts, a Botox-lipped bleached blond announced. Just what do you expect? Everyone else'll do night shifts except you, Myron grumbled back.
从那天起，这几乎成了标准程序。迈伦会坐下，点餐，并留意每一个走进咖啡馆的新人。如果那个人带着期待的眼神搜寻座位，迈伦会迅速招手邀请他或她坐下。我不想这件事闹到法庭，一个眉毛浓密的秃头告诉他。我也是，迈伦让步道。私下解决总是好的。记住，我不做夜班，一个肉毒杆菌嘴唇的漂白金发女郎宣布。你到底想要什么？其他人都会做夜班，就你不行？迈伦回嘴道。
Gabby asked me to tell you that he's sorry, said a guy with rotting teeth and an earring. It he was really sorry, Myron countered, he should have come and told me himself, no middlemen. In your email you sounded taller, a skinny redhead complained. In your email, you sounded less picky, Myron snapped. And somehow everything worked out in the end. He and baldy settled out of court. Botox lips agreed to ask her sister to babysit so she could do one night shift a week. Rotting teeth promised Gabby would phone. And the redhead and Myron agreed they weren't quite right for each other.
加比（Gabby）让我告诉你他很抱歉，一个牙齿腐烂、戴着耳环的家伙说。如果他真的抱歉，迈伦反驳道，他应该亲自来说，别用中间人。在邮件里你听起来更高一些，一个瘦弱的红发女郎抱怨道。在邮件里，你听起来没那么挑剔，迈伦顶了回去。不知何故，最后一切都解决了。他和秃头达成了庭外和解。肉毒嘴唇女同意请她姐姐帮忙看孩子，这样她一周就能做一次夜班。烂牙男承诺加比会打电话。而红发女郎和迈伦同意他们不太适合对方。
Sometimes they picked up the tab. Sometimes he did. With the redhead, they split the bill. And it was all so fascinating that if a whole morning went by when nobody took a seat across from him at the table, Myron felt let down. Luckily this didn't happen too often. Almost two months had gone by since the sweaty fat guy when a pock marked man walked in. Despite the pocked face and the fact that he looked at least 10 years older than Myron, he was good looking, loads of charisma.
有时他们买单。有时他买。和红发女郎一起时，他们分摊账单。这一切太令人着迷了，以至于如果整个早上都没人坐在他对面，迈伦会感到失望。幸运的是这种情况并不常发生。自汗湿胖子离开后，将近两个月过去了，一个满脸麻子的男人走了进来。尽管脸上有麻子，而且看起来比迈伦老至少 10 岁，但他长得很帅，魅力十足。
The first thing he said as he sat down was I was sure you wouldn't show. But we agreed to meet, Myron answered. Yes, said the pock marked guy with a sad smile. Except that after the way I yelled at you on the phone, I was afraid you'd chicken out. So here I am, Myron said, almost teasingly. I'm sorry I yelled at you on the phone, the guy apologized. Really. I just lost it. But I meant every word I said. You got that? I'm asking you to stop seeing her. But I love her, Myron said in a choked voice.
他坐下时说的第一句话是，我确信你不会出现。但我们同意见面了，迈伦回答。是的，麻子脸男人带着忧伤的微笑说。只是在我那样在电话里冲你大喊之后，我担心你会退缩。所以我就在这儿，迈伦几乎是戏谑地说。我很抱歉我在电话里对你大喊，那人道歉道。真的。我只是失控了。但我说的每一句话都是认真的。你明白吗？我要求你别再见她了。但我爱她，迈伦声音哽咽地说。
Sometimes you can love something. And you still have to give it up, the pock marked guy said. Listen to someone a little older than you. Sometimes you have to give it up. Sorry, Myron said. But I can't. Yes you can, the guy shot back. You can. And you will. There's no other way. Maybe we both love her. But I happen to be her husband. And I am not about to let you break up my family. Got that?
有时你可能会爱上某样东西。但你仍然不得不放弃它，麻子脸男人说。听听比你年长一点的人的建议。有时你必须放弃。对不起，迈伦说。但我做不到。是的，你可以，那人反驳道。你可以。你也会的。没有别的路可走。也许我们都爱她。但我碰巧是她的丈夫。我不会让你拆散我的家庭。明白吗？
Myron shook his head. You have no idea what my life has been like this past year, he told the husband. Hell-- not even hell, just one great big stale chunk of nothing. And when you've been living with nothing for so long and suddenly something turns up, you can't just tell it to go away. You understand me, don't you? I know you understand me.
迈伦摇了摇头。你根本不知道我过去这一年过得是什么日子，他告诉丈夫。地狱——甚至算不上地狱，只是一大块陈旧的虚无。当你和虚无相处了这么久，突然间某样东西出现了，你不能仅仅告诉它走开。你理解我，对吧？我知道你理解我。
The husband bit his lower lip. If you see her one more time, he said, I'll kill you. I'm not kidding. And you know it. So kill me, Myron shrugged. That doesn't scare me. We're all going to die in the end. The husband bent down across the table and socked Myron in the jaw. It was the first time in his life that anyone had hit him so hard. And Myron felt the hot wave of pain surge up somewhere in the middle of his face and spread in every direction.
丈夫咬着下唇。如果你再见她一次，他说，我就杀了你。我不是在开玩笑。你知道的。那就杀了我吧，迈伦耸了耸肩。那吓不倒我。我们最终都会死。丈夫俯身越过桌子，狠狠揍了迈伦的下巴一拳。这是他一生中第一次有人打他打得这么重。迈伦感到一股剧痛从脸部中间涌起，并向四面八方蔓延。
Seconds later he found himself on the floor with a husband standing over him. I'll take her away from here, the husband kept shouting as he went on kicking Myron in the stomach and ribs. I'll take her far away to another country. And you won't know where she is. You'll never see her again. You got that, you rotten piece of [BLEEP]. Two waiters jumped the husband and managed somehow to yank him away from Myron. Somebody yelled to the bar man to call the police.
几秒钟后，他发现自己倒在地上，丈夫站在他上方。我会带她离开这里，丈夫大喊着，继续踢迈伦的肚子和肋骨。我会带她去另一个很远的国家。你将不知道她在哪里。你再也见不到她了。明白吗，你这个烂货[哔——]。两名服务员扑向丈夫，设法把他从迈伦身边拉开。有人大喊叫酒保报警。
With his cheek still glued to the coolness of the floor, Myron watched the husband run out of the cafe. One of the waiters bent over and asked him if he was OK. And Myron made an attempt to answer. Do you want me to call an ambulance, the waiter asked. Myron whispered that he didn't. Are you sure, the waiter insisted. You're bleeding.
脸颊仍然贴着冰冷的地板，迈伦看着丈夫跑出咖啡馆。一名服务员弯下腰问他是否还好。迈伦试图回答。你想让我叫救护车吗，服务员问。迈伦低声说他不叫。你确定吗，服务员坚持问。你在流血。
Myron nodded slowly and shut his eyes. He tried as hard as he could to imagine himself with that woman, the one he'd never see again. He tried. And for a moment he almost succeeded. His whole body ached. He felt alive.
迈伦慢慢地点了点头，闭上了眼睛。他尽其所能想象自己和那个女人在一起，那个他再也见不到的女人。他试了。片刻间他几乎成功了。全身疼痛。他感到活着。
Actor John Connolly, reading a story by Etgar Keret from his new collection of stories, Suddenly a Knock on the Door. So I don't know if this can be redundant or not. And there wasn't time for it in the radio broadcast of this episode of our show. But here on the podcast and in the online versions, we can go past 59 minutes. And I first read this short story, Healthy Start, I don't know, maybe a year ago. And we knew we'd be preparing it for this week's show and all that. And it was all planned. And then it wasn't until I talked to Etgar on tape for this week's show that he told me that the story was based on a real incident.
演员约翰·康诺利（John Connolly），阅读埃特加·克雷特的新短篇小说集《突然有人敲门》中的一个故事。所以我不知道这是否会多余。而且这个节目的广播中没有时间播放它。但在播客和在线版本中，我们可以超过 59 分钟。我第一次读这个短篇故事《健康的开始》，我不知道，可能是一年前。我们知道我们要为本周的节目准备它等等。一切都计划好了。然后直到我为本周的节目采访埃特加时，他才告诉我这个故事是基于一个真实事件。
You know this story came from a real true story. But here's--
你知道这个故事来自一个真实的故事。但是这里——
What?
什么？
Yeah. You want me to tell you the story?
是的。你想让我讲那个故事吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Well the thing is that I was in Berlin teaching for a semester. And I was lonely as a dog. It was raining. I didn't know anybody. And then one day my journal publisher, who's based in Munich, said that he's coming to Berlin. And he wants to meet me. So he gave me a name of a cafe. And then I went to that cafe. And I saw that the cafe was like the size of a football stadium, you know? And I said how the hell am I going to find this guy. I don't even know how he looks like.
嗯，情况是这样的，我在柏林教书教了一个学期。我像条狗一样孤独。在下雨。我不认识任何人。然后有一天，我的杂志出版商，常驻慕尼黑，说他要来柏林。他想见我。所以他给了我一个咖啡馆的名字。然后我去了那家咖啡馆。我看到那家咖啡馆有足球场那么大，你知道吗？我说，我到底该怎么找到这家伙。我甚至不知道他长什么样。
So I took a table that was just facing the door. And I said, OK. I'm going to wait. And all kinds of people came. About some of them I said maybe that's him, maybe that's him. But then this guy came. And I saw that he was looking with his eyes somebody, as if he was looking for a guy he's supposed to meet. So I waved him. And he came. And he sat in front of me. And he started speaking to me in English, which is a good sign, because this is Germany.
所以我找了一张正对着门的桌子。我说，好的。我要等等。各种各样的人来了。关于其中一些我说也许是他，也许是他。但后来这家伙来了。我看到他在用眼睛寻找某个人，好像在找他应该见的人。所以我对他招手。他过来了。坐在我面前。他开始用英语跟我说话，这算是个好迹象，因为这是在德国。
And he said I couldn't sleep all night. And I said to him, why? And he said I was thinking about your email. And you know it flattered me, you know. Because he's my publisher. He takes me seriously. But when I thought about it, what I wrote in the email is that I couldn't make it 10:30. I could only come at 11. And then so I said to him, and? And he said, and I can't give you 300,000 euros. I can only give you 250,000. But I have them here in cash. Only you have to show me the goods first.
他说我整晚都没睡。我对他说，为什么？他说我在想你的邮件。你知道，这让我很受宠若惊，你知道。因为他是我的出版商。他很重视我。但当我思考它时，我在邮件里写的是我 10 点半去不了。我只能 11 点去。所以我就对他说，然后呢？他说，我不能给你 30 万欧元。我只能给你 25 万。但我带了现金。只是你必须先给我看货。
And then I looked at him. And I said to him, Gil? And he looked at me and he said Samir? And I said this kind of whoops. And he said to me oh, I'm sorry. And he had this big bag, which seemed very heavy. And he took his big bag. And he said some words--
然后我看着他。我对他说，吉尔（Gil）？他看着我说，萨米尔（Samir）？我说，这个——哎呀。他对我说，噢，对不起。他有一个看起来很沉的大包。他拿起他的大包。他说了一些话——
Etgar says that soon enough the German publisher shows up and recognizes Etgar by his author photo, and sits right down. And Etgar says that he cannot concentrate on the conversation at all. All he can think about is what he should have said to that guy before.
埃特加说，很快德国出版商出现了，通过作者照片认出了埃特加，并直接坐了下来。埃特加说他根本无法专注于谈话。他所能想到的就是他之前应该对那个人说的话。
And I thought to myself all the time what would've happened if I just said to him OK. I'm OK with the 250,000 euros. But what's this I want to check the goods first? Did I ask you to see the money first? if you don't trust me, don't do business with me. And I went with this sentence in my head home. And I got home. I wrote the story.
我一直对自己想，如果我只是对他说好吧，那会发生什么呢。我接受 25 万欧元。但我想先检查货物是怎么回事？我要求你先看钱了吗？如果你不信任我，就别跟我做生意。我脑子里带着这句话回了家。我到家了。我写下了这个故事。
Act Two, Forgive us Our Press Passes. You know how when you call someplace for customer service, and you're on some 800 number, and somebody answers the phone and says her name is Jill, and at some point the thought crosses your mind-- this person's name is probably not Jill. This person is probably sitting in a call center in India or somewhere. And you have that thought, what other jobs can we possibly outsource to people far away at this point? Well Sarah Koenig tells this story of a fairly recent addition to the list of jobs.
第二幕，《原谅我们的记者证》。你知道当你打电话到某处寻求客户服务，打 800 开头的号码，有人接电话并说她叫吉尔（Jill），这时脑子里会闪过一个念头——这个人的名字可能不是吉尔。这个人可能坐在印度的某个呼叫中心。当你产生那个念头时，我们现在还能把什么工作外包给遥远的人呢？莎拉·科尼格（Sarah Koenig）讲述了这个列表中一个相当新的工作的故事。
Back in November, a newspaper reporter named Ryan Smith got an assignment from his editor. Write up a student of the week story for the Houston Chronicle. The student was a senior at Bellaire High School outside Houston.
去年十一月，一位名叫瑞安·史密斯（Ryan Smith）的报纸记者接到了编辑的任务。为《休斯顿纪事报》写一篇本周学生的故事。这名学生是休斯顿郊外贝莱尔高中（Bellaire High School）的一名高年级学生。
So I ended up calling the high school. And it was kind of interesting. Because I talked to the principal a little bit. He was sort of vetting me. And he's like, well why don't you just come by the school tomorrow? And--
所以最后我给高中打了电话。这很有趣。因为我和校长聊了一会儿。他在审查我。他说，那你明天为什么不直接来学校呢？然后——
Why is this even vaguely funny to Ryan? Because Ryan doesn't work for the Houston Chronicle. he's never read the Houston Chronicle. He's never been to Houston. He's never been to Texas. When he made that phone call, he was sitting more than 1,000 miles away in the Midwest. But, of course, the principal of Bellaire High School can't be expected to know that. He probably pictured the newspaper business the way most of us picture it, that Ryan was from the area, that he worked at some crummy office, drove around in a beat up Honda Civic to cover local stories.
为什么这在瑞安看来甚至有点好笑？因为瑞安不在《休斯顿纪事报》工作。他从来没读过《休斯顿纪事报》。他从没去过休斯顿。他从没去过德克萨斯。当他拨打那个电话时，他正坐在 1000 多英里外的中西部。但是，当然，不能指望贝莱尔高中的校长知道这一点。他可能想象报纸行业就像我们大多数人想象的那样，瑞安来自当地，他在某个破旧的办公室工作，开着一辆破本田思域去报道当地的新闻。
And it was a little awkward for me. Because here I am in Chicago. And he's assuming that I'm a reporter in Houston for the Houston Chronicle . So I was like um, why don't we just do this over the phone?
这让我有点尴尬。因为我正坐在芝加哥。而他假设我是《休斯顿纪事报》在休斯顿的记者。所以我说，嗯，我们为什么不通过电话完成呢？
You didn't tell him?
你没告诉他？
I didn't tell him. I just pretended I was from the Chronicle . I was like hopefully that they don't ask. Because I don't really feel like explaining it. Because I don't even understand it completely.
我没告诉他。我只是假装我是《纪事报》的。我说希望他们别问。因为我真的不想解释它。因为我甚至完全不理解它。
What Ryan doesn't understand completely is the brave new world of journalism he's entered. Ryan works for a company that pays people in, say, Chicago, Raleigh, or Boise, to create stories for papers in California, Virginia, or Connecticut, which means embedded in major newspapers all over the country are local notes and stories produced by people who might not know how to pronounce the names of the places they're writing about. They call it hyper-local news. The stories are mostly short, just a paragraph or two sometimes-- the Sheriff's report from York [INAUDIBLE] County, Virginia, who died in Poughkeepsie, New York, and who got a marriage license in Pearland, Texas, the names of all the kids on the headmaster's list at Trinity Preparatory School in Winter Park, Florida.
瑞安完全不理解的是他进入的新闻业的新勇敢世界。瑞安为一家公司工作，这家公司支付在芝加哥、罗利或博伊西等地的人费用，为加利福尼亚、弗吉尼亚或康涅狄格州的报纸制作故事，这意味着嵌入全国各地的主要报纸中的是当地的记录和故事，由那些可能不知道如何读他们所写地方名字的人制作。他们称之为“超本地新闻”。故事大多很短，有时只有一两段——弗吉尼亚州约克县警长的报告，谁在纽约州波基普西去世了，谁在德克萨斯州皮尔兰获得了结婚证，佛罗里达州温特帕克三一预备学校校长名单上的所有孩子的名字。
They do bowling scores, and school lunch menus, and real estate transfers, and holiday trash pickup schedules. Nothing is too small. And the engine of this whole endeavor is data, tons of data that the company mines, and sorts, and enters into databases, public information, and also harder to find records. It works like an assembly line. One person does research. Another generates a lead. Another writes it. Sometimes a couple of paragraphs might be written by computer using an algorithm. And someone else edits it.
他们做保龄球分数、学校午餐菜单、房地产转让和假日垃圾收集时间表。没有什么是太小的。整个努力的引擎是数据，公司挖掘、分类并输入数据库的成吨数据，公共信息，以及更难找到的记录。它像流水线一样工作。一个人做研究。另一个人生成线索。另一个人写它。有时几段可能是用算法由计算机写的。还有人编辑它。
The goal is to create the largest local news machine ever. In the next few months, they want to quadruple their output to produce 100,000 stories a week. The company behind this vision is called Journatic, or maybe Journatic. Ryan himself isn't sure.
目标是创造有史以来最大的本地新闻机器。在接下来的几个月里，他们想将产出增加四倍，达到每周制作 100,000 个故事。这个愿景背后的公司叫 Journatic，或者叫 Journatic。瑞安自己也不确定。
I've honestly never actually heard it said. But I've always said Journatic.
说实话，我从来没听过它的读法。但我一直说 Journatic。
Why are you assuming it's Journatic and not Journatic?
为什么你假设它是 Journatic 而不是 Journatic？
I mean the way you are saying it, it kind of sounds like heretic. Journatic sounds more like journalism.
我的意思是，按照你的读法，它听起来有点像异教徒（heretic）。Journatic 听起来更像新闻学（journalism）。
It does sound like journalism. But what makes Ryan uneasy is that he's not sure it is journalism. Ryan went to journalism school, has been a reporter for newspapers in Missouri, and California, and Chicago, for a dozen years. He got the Journatic job about a year and a half ago when he saw a tweet about it. He emailed his resume. But he was never interviewed. Eventually he got an email offering him some work.
它确实听起来像新闻学。但让瑞安不安的是，他不确定它是否是新闻学。瑞安上过新闻学院，做了十二年的报纸记者，在密苏里、加利福尼亚和芝加哥工作过。他大约一年半前看到了一个关于它的推文，得到了这份 Journatic 的工作。他通过电子邮件发送了简历。但他从未接受过面试。最后他收到一封电子邮件，提供了他一些工作。
And in fact in all the time he's worked at Journatic, he's never spoken directly to his supervising editor, who sits in St. Louis. They communicate exclusively through the computer. When Ryan has a question about how to do something, his supervisor sometimes answers by posting a private video on YouTube. That's the only time Ryan's ever heard the guy's voice. It's all very future.
事实上，在他为 Journatic 工作的整个时间里，他从未直接与他的主管编辑谈话，主管坐在圣路易斯。他们完全通过计算机交流。当瑞安对如何做某事有疑问时，他的主管有时通过在 YouTube 上发布私人视频来回答。那是瑞安唯一一次听到那个人的声音。这一切都很未来。
After he got the student of the week assignment, Ryan was put in charge of editing death notices and little business briefs for Newsday, a newspaper on Long Island.
接到本周学生任务后，瑞安负责编辑《新闻日报》（Newsday）的讣告和小型商业简报，《新闻日报》是长岛的一份报纸。
And my job was just to copy edit it and again, put it in the database.
我的工作只是复制编辑它，再次把它放进数据库。
And where were these stories coming from? Like who was doing the writing that you were editing?
这些故事是从哪儿来的？就像是谁在做你正在编辑的写作？
I was told, actually, that they're located in the Philippines.
事实上，有人告诉我，他们位于菲律宾。
That everything you were editing was coming from the Philippines?
你正在编辑的一切都来自菲律宾？
That's what I was told at the time, that these obituaries and these business stories were all written in the Philippines.
当时有人是这样告诉我的，这些讣告和商业故事都是在菲律宾写的。
I know, right? In the Philippines-- which means when you look up the death notice, say, of a man named Eugene Squeleney Jr. on newsday.com, you see a story about him. But there's no reporters name attached to it. It just says special to Newsday under the headline. But the story was actually written by someone in the Philippines. Journatics internal records listed her as Diana D. and say that Diane got the story from the obituary website legacy.com and just slightly rewrote the information there.
我知道，对吧？在菲律宾——这意味着当你在 newsday.com 上查找一个名叫尤金·斯奎莱尼（Eugene Squeleney Jr.）的男人的讣告时，你看到了关于他的故事。但没有记者名字附在上面。标题下只写着“特别提供给《新闻日报》”。但故事实际上是由菲律宾的某个人写的。Journatic 的内部记录将她列为戴安娜·D（Diana D.），并说戴安从讣告网站 legacy.com 获取了故事，只是略微重写了那里的信息。
I called Newsday's newsroom to ask about this, why they would use Journatic for this work. I didn't get too far. Mostly I learned that Newsday has exciting hold music. I talked to an editor who didn't want to go on tape. When I pointed out the Squeleney story with no reporter's name on it, just special to Newsday , the editor said, quote, "I am totally unfamiliar with this. I don't know what it is," unquote.
我打电话给《新闻日报》的新闻编辑室询问此事，为什么他们会为这项工作使用 Journatic。我没得到什么进展。我主要是了解到《新闻日报》有令人兴奋的等待音乐。我和一位不想录音的编辑谈过。当我指出那篇没有记者名字、只写着“特别提供给《新闻日报》”的斯奎莱尼故事时，编辑说，引用，“我完全不熟悉这个。我不知道那是什么”，引用结束。
Then I talked to a company spokesman who cheerfully said he'd look into it. But a few days later, I got an email saying he quote, "could not provide any information on this." He wouldn't even say whether Newsday was working with Journatic. Ryan says he learned about the Filipino writers after complaining to his supervisor that the copy he was getting was rife with basic grammar and spelling errors. That's when his editor told him to cut the writer some slack. They weren't native speakers. So Ryan wondered, why do we have these writers at all?
然后我和公司发言人谈过，他愉快地说他会调查此事。但几天后，我收到一封电子邮件，说他引用，“无法提供关于此事的任何信息”。他甚至没说《新闻日报》是否正在与 Journatic 合作。瑞安说他在向主管投诉他得到的稿件充满了基本的语法和拼写错误后，才了解到菲律宾作家的事情。那时他的编辑告诉他给作者一些空间。他们不是母语人士。所以瑞安想，我们为什么有这些作家？
His editor wrote back quote, "well someone has to summarize the obits for the death briefs. And it's cheaper to pay an outsourced writer than to have an American writer editor do it. Unfortunately they're basically paid pennies for these. I have Filipinos asking for better pay on a regular basis. I wish I could do something for them." An ad Journatic placed seeking Filipino writers offered 0.35 to $0.40 per story. I confirmed with a Filipino writer that they are paid 35 to $0.40 a story and more for longer stuff. But wait, there's more. Here's Ryan.
他的编辑回复说，引用，“嗯，必须有人总结讣告作为死亡简报。外包作家比让美国作家编辑做这件事更便宜。不幸的是，他们基本上为此只得到几便士。我经常有菲律宾人要求更好的工资。我希望我能为他们做些什么。”Journatic 刊登的一则寻求菲律宾作家的广告提供每篇故事 0.35 到 0.40 美元。我与一位菲律宾作家确认，他们每篇故事获得 35 到 40 美分，更长的东西更多。但是等等，还有更多。这是瑞安。
When I ended up looking at the names on a lot of the stories-- and the names on the stories that were published weren't the ones that I saw that had written the stories.
当我最终查看许多故事上的名字时——出版的故事上的名字不是我看到的写故事的人的名字。
Here's what he's talking about. In the Chicago Tribune's local site covering the towns of Homewood and Flossmoor, for example, you can see that Eric and Joan So-and-so have listed for sale their 4 bedroom, 4.5 bath home on such-and-such a street for $695,000, that Eric is a general manager of a building company, that he attended Roosevelt University. And there's a picture of him.
这就是他在说的。例如在报道霍姆伍德（Homewood）和弗洛斯穆尔（Flossmoor）镇的《芝加哥论坛报》本地网站上，你可以看到埃里克（Eric）和琼（Joan）某某某已经挂牌出售他们在某某街的 4 卧室、4.5 浴室房屋，售价 695,000 美元，埃里克是一家建筑公司的总经理，他毕业于罗斯福大学。还有他的照片。
The reporters name on the story is Jenny Cox. But there is no Jenny Cox. Or even if there is a Jenny Cox somewhere out there, she didn't write the story. The writer was someone named Giselle Bautista in the Philippines who works for Journatic. Again, looking at the computer system the company uses to manage its stories, it seems that when Giselle worked on this real estate story, there was a button called Select Alias. When she clicked on it, she had a choice. She could either be Jenny Cox or Glenda Smith.
故事上的记者名字是珍妮·考克斯（Jenny Cox）。但没有珍妮·考克斯。或者即使外面有珍妮·考克斯，她也没写这个故事。作家是菲律宾一个名叫吉赛尔·包蒂斯塔（Giselle Bautista）的人，她为 Journatic 工作。再次查看公司管理故事的计算机系统，似乎当吉赛尔从事这个房地产故事时，有一个叫“选择别名”的按钮。当她点击它时，她有一个选择。她可以是珍妮·考克斯或者是格伦达·史密斯（Glenda Smith）。
Journatics real estate stories come from a real estate website it also owns, called BlockShopper. Some other fake names that have made their way onto the news sites of Journatics clients in the real estate sections-- Carrie Reed, Amy Anderson, Jay Brownstown, Christine Scott, Bettie Verdoon, Sam Andrews, Carla Andrews, Deana Andrews, Sienna Andrews, Cindy Valens, Angie Barrett, CJ Marx, John Simon, Shania Samson, Scott Johnson, and my favorite--
Journatic 的房地产故事来自它也拥有的一个房地产网站，叫 BlockShopper。在 Journatic 客户的房地产部分新闻网站上出现的一些其他假名字——凯莉·里德（Carrie Reed）、艾米·安德森（Amy Anderson）、杰伊·布朗斯顿（Jay Brownstown）、克里斯汀·斯科特（Christine Scott）、贝蒂·弗杜恩（Bettie Verdoon）、萨姆·安德鲁斯（Sam Andrews）、卡拉·安德鲁斯（Carla Andrews）、迪娜·安德鲁斯（Deana Andrews）、西耶娜·安德鲁斯（Sienna Andrews）、辛迪·瓦伦斯（Cindy Valens）、安吉·巴雷特（Angie Barrett）、CJ·马克思（CJ Marx）、约翰·西蒙（John Simon）、莎妮娅·桑姆森（Shania Samson）、斯科特·约翰逊（Scott Johnson），以及我最喜欢的——
Who is Jimmy Finkle?
谁是吉米·芬克尔（Jimmy Finkle）？
I have no idea. He sounds like a game show host kind of.
我不知道。他听起来像某种游戏节目的主持人。
I feel like he sounds like a Jewish gangster. You talk to Jimmy Finkle, the Finks. He'll straighten you out. So you don't know who Jimmy Finkle is.
我觉得他听起来像个犹太黑帮。你跟吉米·芬克尔谈谈，芬克家族。他会帮你摆平的。所以你不知道吉米·芬克尔是谁。
I have no idea.
我不知道。
Yet you have edited a story with the byline of Jerry Finkle.
然而你编辑过一篇署名为杰里·芬克尔（Jerry Finkle）的故事。
Correct.
正确。
So who wrote it?
那是谁写的？
Well--
嗯——
All of this seems wrong to Ryan, which is why he doesn't tell most people where he works. He's embarrassed.
这一切对瑞安来说似乎都是错的，这就是为什么他不告诉大多数人他在哪儿工作。他感到尴尬。
It's sort of a tattered product that's being written overseas, and half-heartedly edited, and just kind of slopped on the page. And journalism is supposed to be sort of like a local institution, and written by people that care about what's going on there. When I was a reporter on the Daily Beat , sometimes it was hard. Sometimes you had to agonize over things. And sometimes you had to make tough decisions. And you didn't always get things right, and things like that. And you actually cared about it.
这是一种在海外编写的破旧产品，心不在焉地编辑，只是随便写在页面上。新闻学应该像是一个当地的机构，由关心那里发生什么的人编写。当我是《每日节拍》（Daily Beat）的记者时，有时很难。有时你不得不为事情烦恼。有时你不得不做艰难的决定。你并不总是把事情做对，诸如此类。你实际上关心它。
With this, I was writing stories. And I don't know those communities. And I have no stake in them. And so it didn't matter to me that I found out all the information and I got it right. And so there is just something inauthentic about the whole process. And the picking of fake names for these writers in the Philippines is just a symptom of that. The whole thing--
有了这个，我写故事。我不了解那些社区。我对它们没有任何利害关系。所以对我来说，我发现了所有信息并做对并不重要。所以整个过程就是有什么东西不真实。为菲律宾的这些作家挑选假名字只是这的一个症状。这一切——
When Ryan agreed to this interview, I didn't realize he was going to be quite so frank.
当瑞安同意接受这次采访时，我没意识到他会如此坦率。
Oh my god. Ryan, you are so fired.
天哪。瑞安，你被解雇了。
I am.
我是。
And are you OK with that?
你没事吧？
Um, yeah.
嗯，是的。
When he agreed to do this interview, Ryan figured he'd be fired afterwards. But he says it's worth it if he can do something good for journalism. He says the work he does at Journatic has been weighing on his conscience. But there's another side to this, one that turns everything Ryan thinks about local reporting on its head.
当他同意接受这次采访时，瑞安想他之后会被解雇。但他说如果他能为新闻业做点好事，那是值得的。他说他在 Journatic 所做的工作一直压在他的良心上。但还有另一面，这把瑞安对本地报道所想的一切都颠倒了。
I personally think that we're saving journalism with our approach.
我个人认为我们用我们的方法拯救了新闻业。
This is Brian Timpone, Ryan's boss's boss's boss, the founder and CEO of Journatic. And it is pronounced Journatic, by the way. Timpone says it's a mix of journalism and automatic. When I first spoke to him on the phone, he began talking a mile a minute. First of all, he loved our radio show. I'm not kidding. I'm president of your fan club. And I'm not saying this just so you'll give me favorable treatment. I mean I know you're going to make me look bad. But I don't care. I'll deal with it. Because I believe in what we're doing. We're doing God's work. We're not, like, evil. I used to be a reporter.
这是布莱恩·廷波恩（Brian Timpone），瑞安的老板的老板的老板，Journatic 的创始人和 CEO。顺便说一下，它读作 Journatic。廷波恩说这是新闻学（journalism）和自动（automatic）的混合。当我第一次在电话里与他交谈时，他开始以每分钟一英里的速度说话。首先，他喜欢我们的广播节目。我不开玩笑。我是你们粉丝俱乐部的会长。我这么说不仅仅是为了让你给我优惠待遇。我的意思是，我知道你会让我看起来很糟糕。但我不在乎。我会处理它的。因为我相信我们在做的事情。我们在做上帝的工作。我们不是，像，邪恶的。我以前是记者。
Needless to say, I liked him right away. And I wanted to understand how what he was doing would save journalism. Timpone's premise is that what he calls the single reporter model, the old way of doing local reporting, that Ryan used to do and that I used to do as a local reporter-- that it just doesn't work, and that it hasn't really worked in 30 or 40 years.
不用说，我立刻就喜欢他了。我想了解他在做什么会如何拯救新闻业。廷波恩的前提是，他称之为单一记者模式，旧的做本地报道的方式，瑞安过去常做而我也作为本地记者常做的方式——它就是不管用，而且它在 30 或 40 年里并没有真正管用。
It's going to get better if we do it this way. That's my belief.
如果我们这样做，它会变得更好。那是我的信仰。
What's going to get better?
什么会变得更好？
Journalism is going to get better.
新闻业会变得更好。
How?
怎么变？
We need to see more things. No one covers suburban America. No one covers all these small towns. Look at that story in-- was in Dixon, Illinois, that lady stole like 30 million bucks?
我们需要看到更多东西。没有人报道郊区的美国。没有人报道所有这些小镇。看看那个故事在——在伊利诺伊州的迪克森（Dixon），那个女士偷了大约 3000 万美元？
It was actually 53 million bucks in the end. The town controller had been siphoning taxpayer money off the budget for 20 years before another city worker filling in for her stumbled on it.
实际上最后是 5300 万美元。城市主计长在另一个城市工作人员代她填补空缺偶然发现之前，已经从预算中挪用了 20 年的纳税人资金。
How'd that happen? No one was watching. And I'm not saying we're the solution. But we're certainly on the road to the solution. We're going to look at that stuff and help our partners. And there's 400 people or something in the Chicago Tribune newsroom. And they couldn't cover Dixon. They had enough on their plate. There's a darn daily newspaper in that town. I live in River Forest. There's a weekly paper there. And Maywood, next to me-- there's nothing-- literally nothing.
那是怎么发生的？没有人看守。我不是说我们是解决方案。但我们当然走在通往解决方案的路上。我们会看那些东西并帮助我们的伙伴。芝加哥论坛报新闻编辑室有 400 人左右。他们无法报道迪克森。他们手头有足够的事情要做。那个镇上有一份该死的日报。我住在河森林（River Forest）。那里有一份周报。还有我旁边的梅伍德（Maywood）——什么都没有——简直什么都没有。
Yeah.
是的。
Not a single paper covering the town. Isn't that scary? So how is that going to get solved?
没有一份报纸报道那个镇。那不可怕吗？那么那将如何得到解决？
The most radical part of Timpone's pitch, at least to me, is that if you're trying to cover a town like say, Flossmoor, south of Chicago, being on the ground is actually a hindrance.
廷波恩推销中最激进的部分，至少对我来说，是如果你试图报道像，比如，弗洛斯穆尔（Flossmoor），芝加哥以南的一个镇，身处当地实际上是一个障碍。
So you're saying it doesn't matter. It just does it matter. You don't need to be there.
所以你是说它不重要。它不重要。你不需要在那儿。
What I'm saying is go to Flossmoor. We should go together. Let's go walk the streets of Flossmoor together. And tell me what you learn by being there. Let's go live there for six months and tell me if you feel better equipped to cover the budget. You won't be. That's the kind of--
我说的是去弗洛斯穆尔。我们应该一起去。让我们一起走走弗洛斯穆尔的街道。告诉我在那儿你学到了什么。让我们在那儿住六个月，告诉我你是否觉得更有能力去报道预算。你不会的。那是那种——
Really?
真的吗？
Yes, really.
是的，真的。
Really? You really believe that, that after six months of living in Flossmoor, I would have no sense of the community or what was important to the people who live there if I actually talked to human beings who live in Flossmoor?
真的吗？你真的相信吗，在弗洛斯穆尔住六个月后，如果我确实与住在弗洛斯穆尔的人类交谈，我将对社区或对住在那儿的人来说什么重要没有概念？
Here's what I'd say is if you looked at the content we produce, in most cases, you wouldn't even notice it's from a reporter who lives somewhere else, who is writing the same story. It's just done more efficiently.
我会说的是，如果你看看我们制作的内容，在大多数情况下，你甚至不会注意到它是来自住在别处的记者，他写的是同样的故事。它只是完成得更有效率。
You almost said the word cheaply, didn't you?
你差点说了廉价（cheaply）这个词，不是吗？
[INAUDIBLE].
[听不清]。
I heard it start to come out. I heard a ch--
我听到它开始冒出来了。我听到一个 ch——
It is cheaply. But it's not. You got me. Yes.
它是廉价地。但它不是。你抓到我了。是的。
As for the source of that cheap labor, Timpone said, yeah. They've got 100 freelancers offshore, not just in the Philippines, but in Eastern Europe, the former Soviet Republics, Brazil, and Africa. In the US, they've got 200 more, plus 50 US staffers and growing. If you want to see what Journatic can do for a big metro paper, look at the Chicago Tribune . About five years ago, long before they hooked up with Journatic, the Tribune decided to get into the community news business. Brad Moore, vice president of Targeted Media for the Tribune Company, told me that they were looking to bring in money, same as a lot of big metro dailies.
至于那廉价劳动力来源，廷波恩说，是的。他们有 100 个海外自由职业者，不仅在菲律宾，还在东欧、前苏联共和国、巴西和非洲。在美国，他们有 200 多人，加上 50 个美国员工并且在成长。如果你想看看 Journatic 能为一份大都会报纸做什么，看看《芝加哥论坛报》。大约五年前，在他们与 Journatic 挂钩很久之前，论坛报决定进入社区新闻业务。论坛报公司有针对性的媒体副总裁布拉德·摩尔（Brad Moore）告诉我，他们正在寻求引入资金，和许多大都会日报一样。
The notion is that if you can capture local advertising dollars, then you're not so dependent on big national accounts which can cripple your finances if they pull out. So under the title TribLocal, the Chicago Tribune launched 90 websites and 22 weekly print editions covering towns all around Chicago. To staff the sites, Tribune hired 18 reporters. But Brad Moore told me that model just didn't work. Reporters weren't generating enough stories to keep people coming to the websites. And hiring a bunch more reporters was too expensive.
这个概念是，如果你能抓住当地的广告收入，那么你就不会那么依赖大的国家账户，如果他们撤出，它们会使你的财务瘫痪。所以以 TribLocal 的名义，《芝加哥论坛报》发起了 90 个网站和 22 个涵盖芝加哥周围所有城镇的周刊印刷版。为了给这些网站配备人员，论坛报雇佣了 18 名记者。但布拉德·摩尔告诉我，那个模式就是不管用。记者们没有产生足够的故事来保持人们访问这些网站。并且雇佣一堆更多的记者太昂贵了。
So this spring, Tribute higher Journatic. It actually bought a share in the company to run TribLocal. As part of the switch over, the Tribune laid off about half of its 40 person TribLocal staff, including seven reporters. Another 11 reporters were sent to Tribune's larger suburban bureaus. Here's Brad Moore from the Trib .
所以今年春天，论坛报雇佣了 Journatic。它实际上购买了这家公司的一份股份来经营 TribLocal。作为转换的一部分，论坛报解雇了大约一半的 40 人 TribLocal 员工，包括 7 名记者。另外 11 名记者被派往论坛报更大的郊区局。这是来自论坛报的布拉德·摩尔。
So far, we're very happy with what Journatic is doing for us. We're getting a lot more content.
到目前为止，我们非常高兴 Journatic 为我们所做的。我们得到了更多的内容。
And when you say you're getting more content, how much more content?
当你说是你得到了更多的内容，多了多少内容？
It looks from a sheer volume standpoint, about three times the amount of content pieces that we had before.
它看起来从纯粹的体量立场，大约是我们之前拥有的内容件数的三倍。
And for cheaper, for less money.
而且更便宜，花了更少的钱。
In most cases, yes. And then we're already looking at ways to reinvest those savings into more towns. We've actually launched two additional towns in TribLocal that we weren't in before, Homewood, and Flossmoor, and Oaklawn-- actually three towns. We're looking at the city of Chicago to see what neighborhoods we might want to launch into. So yes, it's more content. It's at a savings. But more excitingly, we hope to take that savings and reinvest it into more coverage.
在大多数情况下，是的。然后我们已经在寻找将那些储蓄再投资到更多城镇的方法。我们实际上在 TribLocal 发起了两个额外的城镇，我们之前没在其中，霍姆伍德（Homewood）、弗洛斯穆尔（Flossmoor）和奥克朗（Oaklawn）——实际上是三个城镇。我们正在看看芝加哥市，看看我们可能想进入哪些社区。所以是的，这是更多的内容。这是一种节省。但更令人兴奋的是，我们希望利用那些节省并将其再投资到更多的报道中。
Brad Moore said the TribLocal local sites are getting more web traffic now the Jounatic has taken over. And Moore says he has no problem with out of state or offshore workers generating news briefs and small stories. But the subject was sensitive enough that he didn't want to discuss on tape who was writing what and under what name. Because no newspaper wants the story about them to be Tribune Fires American Writers, Hires Filipinos for Cheaper. All he would say on tape about it was this--
布拉德·摩尔说，TribLocal 本地网站现在正在获得更多的网络流量，现在 Journatic 已经接管了。摩尔说他对州外或海外工作人员生成新闻简报和小故事没有问题。但这个主题很敏感，他不想在录音中讨论谁在写什么以及以什么名字。因为没有报纸想要关于他们的故事是《论坛报解雇美国作家，雇佣菲律宾人作为更便宜》。他在录音中唯一能说的关于它的是这个——
Just to be clear, all of the writing and editing of everything that Journatic is doing is happening by professional journalists here in the US.
为了清楚起见，Journatic 正在做的所有一切写作和编辑都是由这里的专业记者在美国进行的。
I went around and around about this with both Brad Moore and Brian Timpone who insisted that Filipinos were not writing stories. They were more like typing information, assembling it in paragraph form, which sounds to me a lot like writing. Brian Timpone told me this was a semantic confusion I was having.
我和布拉德·摩尔和布莱恩·廷波恩绕来绕去，他们坚持说菲律宾人没有在写故事。他们更像是输入信息，以段落形式组装它，这听起来对我来说很像写作。布莱恩·廷波恩告诉我，这是我正在经历的语义混淆。
Really what they're doing is assembling and copy editing a bunch of facts, right? So they write the lead. If there's a paragraph about a person, the paragraph is technically written by someone in the Philippines, but not written. It's like they have to type out who the person is, right? So they have to know how to write to send it over. I mean but to say oh, it's written in the Philippines-- I mean there might be a paragraph of it that the first draft is written in the Phillipines.
实际上他们所做的是组装和复制编辑一堆事实，对吧？所以他们写导语。如果有一个关于某人的段落，这个段落技术上是由在菲律宾的某人写的，但没写。就像他们必须输入那个人是谁，对吧？所以他们必须知道如何写以发送它过来。我的意思是，但要说噢，它是在菲律宾写的——我的意思是可能有一个段落是第一稿是在菲律宾写的。
Timpone declined to put me in touch with any of his Filipino employees. But I reached out to half a dozen of them on my own.
廷波恩拒绝让我接触他的任何菲律宾员工。但我自己联系了六个。
You yourself are writing those stories, right? You're not just gathering the information and sending it along to an American writer or editor. You yourself are writing those.
你自己正在写那些故事，对吧？你不仅仅是在收集信息并把它发送给美国作家或编辑。你自己正在写那些。
Yeah.
是的。
That one word is all you're going to hear from this particular worker at his request. He's got a full time professional job. But he told me his Journatic work pays better. And he needs the money to help pay his family's expenses. Plus he likes the work. Back in April when the Tribune announced that Journatic would be providing stories for TribLocal , some readers and media watchers instantly began to grumble about the job losses but also about the product. It was canned, they said, barely rewritten press releases and daily stories under the news section about top DVD rentals in town or where to find the cheapest gas according to gasbuddy.com. No context, no analysis.
那个词是你将从这个特定员工那里听到的全部，应他的请求。他有一份全职专业工作。但他告诉我他的 Journatic 工作报酬更好。他需要钱来帮助支付他家庭的费用。加上他喜欢这份工作。早在四月当论坛报宣布 Journatic 将为 TribLocal 提供故事时，一些读者和媒体观察者立刻开始抱怨失业，但也抱怨产品。那是罐装的，他们说，几乎没重写的发布稿和新闻部分下的日常故事关于镇上顶尖 DVD 租赁或者根据 gasbuddy.com 在哪里找到最便宜的汽油。没有背景，没有分析。
Chicago Media columnist, Robert Feder, wrote, "I used to look forward to receiving TribLocal , the weekly hyperlocal news insert in my Chicago Tribune . But now it's become a worthless piece of garbage. Major news stories in my suburb are completely ignored. In its first three weeks, I've seen nothing in this new rag but press releases, computer generated junk, and of course ads. What passes for a police blotter is a long list of street names, one and two word descriptions, and a time and date," unquote.
芝加哥媒体专栏作家罗伯特·费德（Robert Feder）写道，“我曾经期待接收 TribLocal，我《芝加哥论坛报》中的每周超本地新闻插页。但现在它已成为毫无价值的垃圾。我郊区的主要新闻故事完全被忽视。在前三周，我在这份新的破报纸中除了发布稿、计算机生成的垃圾，当然还有广告，什么都没看见。什么通过作为警察记录的是一长串街道名称、一两个词描述以及时间和日期，”引用结束。
Journatic does longer stories too that actually require real reporting. But even there the quality is questionable. Take this story Ryan Smith wrote for TribLocal about the Flossmoor village budget. Flossmoor is one of the towns the Trib started covering when Journatic took over, a small upper middle class town south of Chicago. Ryan had never been to Flossmoor. But he looked at the budget online and called the village's finance director. His lead was at the village board had passed the budget, quote, "which the board says reflects a healthy state of the villages finances."
Journatic 也做需要真实报道的更长的故事。但即使在那里，质量也是有问题的。看看瑞安·史密斯为 TribLocal 写的关于弗洛斯穆尔村预算的故事。弗洛斯穆尔是论坛报在 Journatic 接管时开始报道的城镇之一，芝加哥以南的一个小型中上层城镇。瑞安从没去过弗洛斯穆尔。但他在线看了预算并给村里的财务总监打了电话。他的导语是村委员会已经通过了预算，引用，“委员会说这反映了村庄财务的健康状况。”
But Ryan didn't know whether there was any argument over the budget or taxes beforehand. Again he had never covered the town before.
但瑞安不知道在预算或税收上是否事先有任何争论。再次，他从没报道过那个镇。
I'm sure there was a public meeting. And there may have been people that were upset about the way that they were spending their money. Maybe they were upset that $500,000 is being used to replace the streetlights. But I didn't see those people. I didn't know if there were any objections.
我确信有一个公开会议。并且可能有人对他们花钱的方式感到不安。也许他们对 50 万美元被用于更换路灯感到不安。但我没看见那些人。我不知道是否有任何反对意见。
And you weren't going to call around and find out was there any dissent? Was anybody at the meeting?
你没打算到处打电话并找出是否有异议吗？有人在会议上吗？
I wasn't told to. I was told to talk to one source and then just get a couple quotes basically, and then just plug it in. I just had to talk to some city official, who is going to want to paint the city in the best light possible. So you don't get the other side with this kind of reporting.
没人告诉我。我被告知与一个来源交谈，然后基本上只是得到几个引用，然后只是把它插进去。我只需要和某个城市官员谈谈，他会想以最好的光线描绘城市。所以你不会得到这种报道的另一面。
Of course Ryan could've made a few more calls to find out if there had been any controversy. But it wasn't worth his while.
当然瑞安本可以多打几个电话找出是否有任何争议。但这不值得。
Especially for a reporter, for a freelance writer, if you're only getting paid $12 for a story, it's not really in your interest to do a proper reporter's job on it.
特别是对记者，对自由撰稿人，如果你一篇故事只得到 12 美元，做适当的记者工作真的不符合你的利益。
Is that what you got paid, $12?
这是你得到的报酬，12 美元吗？
For this story, yeah, I believe it's $12 or $14.
对于这个故事，是的，我相信它是 12 或 14 美元。
Ryan spent three or four hours on the story, which means he was paid something like $4 an hour. At that rate, it makes a lot more sense for you to churn out as many $12 stories as you can as fast as you can, which means you don't call more than one source. And you might miss the meaning of your story. There actually is a suburban paper which covers Flossmoore. It's called the South Town Star . I called its managing editor, Joe Biesk. And he said they sent a freelancer, who lives in Flossmoore, to that budget meeting, which Ryan never attended.
瑞安在这个故事上花了三四个小时，这意味着他每小时大约被支付 4 美元。以那个费率，让你尽可能多地 churn 出 12 美元的故事越快越好更有意义，这意味着你不会打给超过一个来源。并且你可能会错过你故事的意义。实际上有一份郊区报纸报道弗洛斯穆尔。它叫《南镇之星》（South Town Star）。我给它的总编辑乔·比斯克（Joe Biesk）打了电话。他说他们派了一个住在弗洛斯穆尔的自由撰稿人去参加那个预算会议，瑞安从没参加过。
The freelancer told her editor that the budget passed by the village board was a continuation of the one already in place, and there was nothing that stood out to her. So Biesk said, we made an editorial decision not to run a story.
自由撰稿人告诉她的编辑，村委员会通过的预算是已经到位的预算的延续，对她来说没有什么突出的。所以比斯克说，我们做了一个编辑决定不运行故事。
That's the old way. Go to the meeting. Consider the context. And then decide whether it's newsworthy. Journatics' way is just the facts, lots and lots of facts.
那是旧方式。去开会。考虑背景。然后决定它是否具有新闻价值。Journatic 的方式只是事实，很多很多事实。
Journatics founder, Brian Timpone, understands that his company doesn't do perfect reporting. Stop comparing us to the New York Times , he told me. All we are saying is, if you want to do community news, cover places you've never covered before, Journatic can get you started.
Journatic 的创始人布莱恩·廷波恩明白他的公司不做完美的报道。停止把我们和《纽约时报》比较，他告诉我。我们所说的只是，如果你想做社区新闻，报道你从未报道过的地方，Journatic 可以让你开始。
And if Journatic does the busy work, it frees up real staff reporters at papers like the Trib , or the Houston Chronicle , or the Hartford Current , to do more substantial hard hitting work. And it gives these reporters access to all kinds of data they might have had before. All those school board minutes, and village budgets, and city council agendas nobody wants to look at-- Timpone's saying we'll look at them.
如果 Journatic 做繁重的工作，它释放了在像论坛报、《休斯顿纪事报》或《哈特福德新闻》（Hartford Current）这样的报纸上的真实员工记者去做更实质性的艰巨工作。并且它给了这些记者接触他们以前可能有的所有数据。所有那些没人想看的学校董事会记录、村预算和市议会议程——廷波恩说我们会看它们。
I would posit that it's better to have somebody look at them than to have nobody look at them. You know what? Newspapers are firing people. Newspapers are struggling. They're going bankrupt. We have a solution that helps solve the problem, right? Cutting staff is not the way to growth. But empowering a reporter with people in the Philippines-- that's a really smart thing to do. The criticism's fine. But at the end of the day, what's a better solution?
我会断定，有人看它们比没人看它们更好。你知道吗？报纸正在解雇人。报纸正在挣扎。它们正在破产。我们有一个有助于解决问题的解决方案，对吧？裁减员工不是增长的方式。但用菲律宾人赋予记者权力——那是一件非常聪明的事情。批评很好。但归根结底，什么是更好的解决方案？
Yeah.
是的。
I mean do you have one? Tell me if you have a better idea, I'm all ears.
我的意思是你有吗？如果你有更好的主意告诉我，我洗耳恭听。
I don't have a better idea. And the newspaper business as a whole doesn't seem to have a better idea, not unless consumers want to start paying properly for their news. So many newspapers are floundering and bleeding staff. According to the website Paper Cuts, something like 35,000 people have lost newspaper jobs since 2008 because of layoffs and buyouts. Unlike most newspapers in America, Journatic is hiring.
我没有更好的主意。作为一个整体的报纸行业似乎也没有更好的主意，除非消费者想要开始为他们的新闻支付适当的费用。这么多报纸正在挣扎和流失员工。根据网站 Paper Cuts，自 2008 年以来，大约有 35,000 人因为裁员和买断失去了报纸工作。与美国大多数报纸不同，Journatic 正在招聘。
Sarah Keonig. She's one of the producers of our program. After she asked Brian Timpone about the fake names on certain stories that Journatic publishes, Timpone told her that Journatic decided to eliminate the fake names. Brad Moore of the Chicago Tribune told us that the Trib is not going to allow them any more either. The stories that Filipino writers work on will be credited to the editors of the stories. We will get a generic byline like Neighborhood News Service. The real Filipinos' names will not appear in the paper.
莎拉·科尼格（Sarah Keonig）。她是我们要节目的制作人之一。在她问布莱恩·廷波恩关于 Journatic 发布某些故事上的假名字后，廷波恩告诉她 Journatic 决定消除假名字。《芝加哥论坛报》的布拉德·摩尔告诉我们论坛报也不会再允许它们了。菲律宾作家从事的故事将被记在故事的编辑身上。我们将得到一个通用的署名像邻里新闻服务。真正的菲律宾人的名字不会出现在报纸上。
Coming up, learning to eat fish eyes and suck marrow from chicken bones to get close to mom. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
即将到来，学习吃鱼眼并从鸡骨头中吮吸骨髓以接近妈妈。那是在一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Switcharoo, people pretending to be something they are not, sometimes harmlessly, sometimes not so harmlessly, sometimes it's hard to tell which one it is.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，带给你关于那个主题的不同种类的故事。今天的节目，《移花接木》，人们假装成不是他们的东西，有时无害，有时不那么无害，有时很难分辨它是哪个。
We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, Runaway Groom. We close our show today with parents who are pretending to be parents, though as you'll hear sometimes not pretending very hard. Jackie Clarke tells what happened.
我们已经到达了我们节目的第三幕。第三幕，《逃跑的新郎》。我们今天用假装是父母的父母结束我们的节目，虽然正如你将听到的有时假装得并不努力。杰基·克拉克（Jackie Clarke）讲述了发生了什么。
The life rules my father would announce to my brother, my sister, and me, were never rules that any other parents seemed to have, like when I was five and he told me, a real woman doesn't drink beer, especially from a can. Or you ever notice that only ugly people end up on welfare? Or the time he was teaching me to use a handgun in our backyard in suburban Massachusetts. Always shoot to kill, Jackie, never to wound. Shoot to kill. I was 10.
我父亲会向我哥哥、我姐姐和我宣布的生活规则，从来都不是任何其他父母似乎有的规则，就像我五岁时他告诉我，真正的女人不喝啤酒，特别是从罐子里。或者你有没有注意到只有丑陋的人最后才靠福利？或者那次他在我们马萨诸塞州郊区的后院教我使用手枪。总是射杀，杰基，永远不要伤害。射杀。我 10 岁。
My mom-- I don't remember a lot about. She died when I was in first grade-- complications from diabetes. And for a couple of years after my mom died, my dad did his best to raise us on his own. He made a point of having family dinners. He coached our soccer teams, threw us birthday parties. Eventually he started dating. For a while he was a member of a support group called Parents Without Partners. But he quit because he said it was all chunky broads looking for a husband. That's when the catalogs started arriving.
我妈妈——我不记得太多关于她的事。我在一年级时她去世了——糖尿病并发症。在我妈妈去世后的几年里，我爸爸尽力独自抚养我们。他特意有了家庭晚餐。他指导我们的足球队，给我们办生日聚会。最终他开始约会。有一段时间他是叫“没有伴侣的父母”支持小组的成员。但他退出了，因为他说那全是寻找丈夫的粗壮大妈。那就是目录开始到达的时候。
My dad had decided he wanted a mail order bride. He never hid it from his kids. Over plates of spaghetti he'd passed out the latest mail order bride catalog and tell us to pick out the ones you like. My sister and I always picked out the pretty ones with nice smiles. I don't think we really understand what we were looking at. It seemed like a Sears wish book for moms.
我爸爸已经决定他想要一个邮购新娘。他从不向他的孩子隐藏它。在意大利面盘子上他会分发最新的邮购新娘目录并告诉我们选择你们喜欢的那些。我姐姐和我总是选择漂亮的带着不错微笑的那些。我不认为我们真的理解我们在看什么。它看起来像妈妈的西尔斯愿望书。
Then one day this Filipino beauty arrived. Her name was Pura. She was 25 years old. And she married my father in a Justice of the Peace ceremony. And instead of taking his new bride on a honeymoon, my dad took off for one of his month long business trips overseas. And we three kids were left in the care of a woman he had found in a catalog.
然后有一天这个菲律宾美人到了。她的名字叫普拉（Pura）。她 25 岁。她在治安官仪式上嫁给了我父亲。而不是带着他的新娘去度蜜月，我爸爸动身去他海外的月度商务旅行之一。我们三个孩子被留在一个他在目录中找到的女人的照顾下。
My siblings and I dealt with Pura in different ways. My sister, Allie, made trouble. My brother, Jeff, became invisible. But I was the middle child. And I wanted things to work. I was 100% on board for Pura as our new mother. I asked Pura if I could call her mom. She said call me Pura. I tried to be exactly like her. When Pura ate fish eyes and sucked the marrow out of chicken bones, so did I. Pura told me that when she was a girl, she'd slept with a close pin on her nose to make it look more American. So I started pressing my nose flat to my face to make it look more Filipino.
我的兄弟姐妹和我以不同的方式处理普拉。我姐姐，艾莉（Allie），制造麻烦。我哥哥，杰夫（Jeff），变得隐形。但我是中间的孩子。我想让事情行得通。我 100% 同意普拉作为我们的新母亲。我问普拉我能否叫她妈妈。她说叫我普拉。我试图变得完全像她。当普拉吃鱼眼并从鸡骨头中吮吸骨髓时，我也这样做了。普拉告诉我，当她是个女孩时，她睡觉时鼻子夹着夹子，让它看起来更美国化。所以我开始把我的鼻子压平到我的脸上，让它看起来更菲律宾化。
In fifth grade when my teacher went around the room asking us what nationality we where, I told her Filipino. She looked at my pale freckled skin and blue eyes and asked again. Really? I nodded. Yep, I'm Filipino. Through my whole teenage years, I continued to expect Pura to suddenly start acting like the moms in the Judy Blume books I loved. When I was 12, I asked Pura if she could show me how to shave my legs. I had it in my mind she would jump at the chance. And we would giggle and bond. She wasn't interested.
在五年级当我的老师绕着房间问我们是什么国籍时，我告诉她菲律宾。她看着我苍白的雀斑皮肤和蓝眼睛并再次询问。真的吗？我点了点头。是的，我是菲律宾人。在我整个青少年时期，我继续期待普拉突然开始像我喜爱的朱迪·布鲁姆（Judy Blume）书中的妈妈们那样行事。当我 12 岁时，我问普拉她能否教我如何刮腿毛。我脑子里想她会抓住这个机会。我们会咯咯笑并建立联系。她没兴趣。
When I got my first period, I didn't know what had happened, not because I wasn't expecting it, but because it wasn't red like blood-- more brownish. So I just put my soiled underpants in the laundry hamper. A week later, a giant box of generic sanitary pads appeared on my bed. I asked Pura why they were there. She looked down at me and said, you got your period, stupid.
当我得到我的第一次月经时，我不知道发生了什么，不是因为我没期待它，而是因为它不像血那样红——更褐色。所以我只是把我脏了的内衣放进洗衣篮。一周后，一盒巨大的通用卫生垫出现在我的床上。我问普拉为什么它们在那儿。她看着我并说，你来月经了，笨蛋。
It wasn't that Pura didn't like me. She just had no desire to be a mother to me. And all this made be closer to my dad. He was gone a lot for work, sometimes months at a time. But when he was around, he had this way of swooping in at key moments. He was the one who helped me shave my legs when Pura refused to do it, using his BIC razor and his Edge shaving gel. He was also the one who took me shopping for my first bra.
不是普拉不喜欢我。她只是没有成为我母亲的愿望。而这一切让我和我爸爸更亲近。他因为工作经常不在，有时一走就是几个月。但当他在的时候，他在关键时刻 swooping 进来。他是那个在我姐姐拒绝刮时帮我刮腿毛的人，使用他的 BIC 剃须刀和他的 Edge 剃须凝胶。他也是那个带我去买我第一个胸罩的人。
And I was there for him. You see, his marriage to Pura was never a good one. It was basically hellish fighting followed by silent treatments. And I was my dad's apologist. Whenever Pura or my siblings got mad at my dad, I defended him. I backed him up. So it's not surprising to me that I was the one my dad came to years later when he needed to confess to someone in our family and that he actually had a second family.
并且我在那儿支持他。你看到，他和普拉的婚姻从来不是一段好的婚姻。它基本上是地狱般的争吵伴随着冷暴力。我是我爸爸的辩护者。每当普拉或我的兄弟姐妹对我爸爸生气时，我捍卫他。我支持他。所以我不惊讶多年后当我爸爸需要向我们家里的某人忏悔他实际上有第二个家庭时，我是那个来的人。
I was in college when my dad told me that after only a few years of marriage to Pura and unbeknownst to us all, he had started a new relationship with another Filipino woman. This one lived in the Philippines. Her name was Joedin and they had two children together. I was home on break for Thanksgiving when he broke the news to me, that basically he had been lying to our whole family for years, that his prolonged business trips weren't just for business. They were trips so he could visit and take care of his other family. But I didn't freak out. I wanted to be there for my dad. I knew that, yes, what my father was doing was terrible, and bizarre, and wrong. But somehow my next thought was maybe has a good reason.
我在大学时我爸爸告诉我，在和普拉结婚几年后，我们所有人都不知情，他开始了与另一个菲律宾女人的新关系。这个女人住在菲律宾。她的名字叫乔丁（Joedin），他们有两个孩子。感恩节我回家休息时，他打破了关于他的新闻给我，基本上他多年来一直在对我们整个家庭撒谎，他的延长商务旅行不仅仅是为了商务。它们是旅行，所以他可以探望并照顾他的另一个家庭。但我没 freak out。我想在那儿支持我爸爸。我知道，是的，我父亲所做的是可怕的、离奇的、错误的。但不知何故我的下一个念头是也许他有好的理由。
Finally, after 16 years of marriage, Pura sued my father for divorce. And as a lot of you may know, divorce is hard on everybody. Raise your hand out there if your parents are divorced and they expected you to take sides. That's the worst, right? OK. Now raise your hand if your stepmother snuck into your fathers house and snatched a bunch of documents, and possibly again, and then got so mad she stabbed the couch to death with a kitchen knife.
最终，结婚 16 年后，普拉起诉我父亲离婚。而且正如你们很多人可能知道的，离婚对每个人都很难。如果你父母离婚了并且他们期待你选边站请举手。那是糟糕的，对吧？好的。现在如果你的继母偷偷溜进你父亲的房子并抢走了一堆文件，可能再次，然后变得如此生气，她用菜刀把沙发刺死了请举手。
In a divorce case lasting five years, my father appeared in court a total of 0 times. As the case progressed, the following things about my father became clear. We discovered he had moved almost all of his money to an offshore bank account in the Bahamas. We discovered he had applied for several credit cards in the name of our parrot, Ranya Clark, and then maxed them out. And we discovered that the only checking account he had access to in the United States was in the name of this Thai man my father used to do business with named Peishit Asflopluprong.
在一个持续五年的离婚案中，我父亲总共在法庭上出现了 0 次。随着案件进展，关于我父亲的以下事情变得清楚。我们发现他已经把几乎所有的钱都移到了巴哈马的一个离岸银行账户。我们发现他已经以我们鹦鹉拉尼亚·克拉克（Ranya Clark）的名字申请了几张信用卡，然后把它们透支了。并且我们发现他能进入的唯一一个在美国的支票账户是以这个泰国人我父亲过去与之做生意名叫 Peishit Asflopluprong 的人的名义。
I know it sounds like I'm making up that name, but it's a real name. And the final and most upsetting discovery was when my father informed me he had moved to the Philippines and was going to stay there with no intentions of ever settling his divorce with Pura.
我知道这听起来我在编造那个名字，但它是一个真实的名字。而且最终也是最令人不安的发现是当我父亲通知我他已经搬到菲律宾并且打算留在那里，没有打算永远解决他与普拉的离婚。
So Pura had no other recourse. She sued me and my brother and sister for $200,000. Actually, technically, we had to sue her. You see the judge was going to award Pura the house we all grew up in since my dad was doing nothing to intervene. But this was the house that my mom had left us when she died. it was also the house that my sister and her son, Troy, were currently living in.
所以普拉没有其他 recourse。她起诉我和我哥哥姐姐 20 万美元。实际上，技术上，我们不得不起诉她。你看到法官要把我们长大的房子判给普拉，因为我爸爸什么都没做来干预。但这正是我们在去世时我妈妈留给我们的房子。它也是我姐姐和她儿子特洛伊（Troy）目前居住的房子。
So the three of us fought Pura in court. During the trial the judge made a statement from the bench. She said she admired us kids for sticking together. Then she said my father was not a good man, which was the first time I had heard someone who wasn't married to my father accuse him of that. In the end, we offered Pura a cash settlement. And she accepted. We mortgaged the hell out of the house to get Pura the money. We kids paid for our fathers divorce, $200,000.
所以我们三人在法庭上对抗普拉。在审判期间法官从法庭发表了一项声明。她说她钦佩我们孩子团结在一起。然后她说我父亲不是一个好人，这是我第一次听到不是和我父亲结婚的人指责他。最后，我们给普拉提供了一个现金和解。而且她接受了。我们抵押了房子得到普拉的钱。我们孩子支付了我们父亲的离婚，20 万美元。
The last time I spoke to my dad was about a month after the trial ended. I was in a cab in New York City, late for an appointment. And my father called me from the Philippines. I told them that we lost the court case. And before I could stop myself, I asked him what he thought we should do as if he was going to fix it. I still thought he would do the right thing, that he would be a dad. But he didn't do the right thing. He didn't swoop in and help. He just avoided the question. Then he told me not to give anyone his cell phone number, especially Pura.
我上次和我爸爸交谈是在审判结束一个月后。我在纽约市的出租车里，赶时间赴约。我父亲从菲律宾给我打电话。我告诉他们我们输了法院案件。而且在我阻止自己之前，我问他他认为我们应该怎么做，好像他会修复它。我仍然认为他会做正确的事，他会成为一个爸爸。但他没做正确的事。他没 swoop 进来并帮助。他只是避开了这个问题。然后他告诉我不要给任何人他的手机号码，特别是普拉。
I hung up the phone and burst into tears. And yes, I know it's crazy that I hadn't already written my dad off by this point. I just didn't get it. I knew that Pura was never the mom I so badly wanted. But I just couldn't see that my dad was never really the dad I thought he was. I always thought that of the two of them, he was my one real parent. I was wrong. That was almost the worst part, that I had been in such denial about my dad for so long. What the judge said during our trial was right. My father was not a good man.
我挂断了电话并爆发哭泣。而且是的，我知道这很疯狂，我还没到这一点就已经把我爸爸写下来了。我只是没明白。我知道普拉从来不是我如此渴望的妈妈。但我只是看不出我爸爸从来没真正是我认为的那种爸爸。我一直认为在他们两个之中，他是我的一个真正的父母。我错了。那是几乎最糟糕的部分，我在这么长时间里对我的爸爸有如此的否认。法官在审判期间说的对了。我父亲不是一个好人。
That phone call was seven years ago. I haven't talked to my father since. And that's not a decision I consciously made. I never said I'm never speaking to my father again. It just happened. Then a couple of months ago, I was at work when my sister told me that my father came up as a suggestion on Facebook as one of her people you may know. I asked her to send me the link.
那个电话是七年前。我从那以后没和我父亲交谈过。而且那不是我自觉做出的决定。我从没说我永远不再和我父亲交谈。它只是发生了。然后几个月前，我在工作时我姐姐告诉我我父亲作为一个建议出现在 Facebook 上，作为她的你可能认识的人之一。我让她发链接给我。
I went into my office and pulled up his page. It was so weird seeing him. So much time had passed. He had stopped being a person to me. He had just become an idea, a story I would tell. But there he was on my computer screen, standing on a mountain with his arm around Joedin, his second Filipino bride-- smiling, older, heavier. He was real. And I thought that man-- he's my father.
我进入我的办公室并拉起他的页面。看到他太奇怪了。太多时间过去了。他对我来说已经不再是一个人。他只是变成了一个主意，一个我会告诉的故事。但他就在那儿，在我的电脑屏幕上，站在山上，胳膊搂着乔丁，他的第二个菲律宾新娘——微笑着，更老，更重。他是真实的。而且我想那个男人——他是我的父亲。
Jackie Clarke. She's a comedian who currently writes for the ABC sitcom, Happy Endings. Her Twitter handle is JackieClarke. It may not come as a surprise that some facts in this story are in dispute. Pura declined to comment about whether she took some documents and maybe a gun from her husband and-or stabbed a couch. Jackie's dad, who we reached by email, suggested that Jackie is an embellisher and quote, "a rather vulgar comedian." Her dad wrote that he did not have offshore bank accounts, though court documents indicate that, in fact, he did. Jackie's dad said he did have a checking account under the name Peishit Asflopluprong, but quote, "under agreement and request by a Thai Chinese associate," end quote.
杰基·克拉克。她是一个喜剧演员，目前为 ABC 情景喜剧《幸福结局》（Happy Endings）写作。她的推特句柄是 JackieClarke。这可能不会让人惊讶，这个故事中的一些事实存在争议。普拉拒绝评论她是否从她丈夫那儿拿走了一些文件和可能一把枪和或者把沙发刺死了。杰基的爸爸，我们通过电子邮件联系到的，暗示杰基是一个修饰者和引用，“一个相当庸俗的喜剧演员。”她爸爸写道他没有离岸银行账户，虽然法庭文件显示，事实上，他确实有。杰基的爸爸说他确实有一个以泰国华人助理的名义的支票账户，但引用，“在泰国华人助理的协议和请求下，”引用结束。
He wrote that he did not apply for credit cards in the family parrot's name, though he did confirm that it's name is Rayna. Rayna is still alive. Asked if he is now or has ever been on Facebook, he replied, quote, "I do not engage in social advertising sites," end quote. Jackie's sister and brother told us that they have the same memories of her father doing these things that Jackie does.
他写道他没有以家庭鹦鹉的名字申请信用卡，虽然他确实确认它的名字是雷纳（Rayna）。雷纳还活着。问他现在是否或曾经在 Facebook 上，他回复，引用，“我不从事社会广告网站，”引用结束。杰基的姐姐和哥哥告诉我们他们有她父亲做这些事情的同样记忆，就像杰基那样。
Our program was produced today by Ben Calhoun, with Alex Blumberg, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Manjivar, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon is our office manager, production help from Matt Kilty. Music help from Damien Grey, from Rob Gettis. Special thanks today to Michelle Harris.
我们的节目今天由本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、莎拉·科尼格（Sarah Koenig）、乔纳森·曼吉瓦尔（Jonathan Manjivar）、丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞门（Robyn Semien）、阿里萨·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普戴克（Nancy Updike）。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）是我们的办公室经理，马特·基尔蒂（Matt Kilty）提供制作帮助。音乐帮助来自达米恩·格雷（Damien Grey），来自罗伯·盖蒂斯（Rob Gettis）。特别感谢今天的米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know he has contracted his new memoir to writers in the Philippines. But he insists they are not actually writing the memoir for him. No, no, no. His name will be on the cover.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ 管理 oversight 为我们的节目，由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚先生（Mr. Torey Malatia）。你知道他把他的新回忆录合同给了菲律宾的作家。但他坚持他们实际上没在为他写回忆录。不，不，不。他的名字将在封面上。
If there's a paragraph about a person, the paragraph is technically written by someone in the Philippines, but not written. It's like they have to type it. They have to type out who the person is, right? So they have to know how to write.
如果有一个关于某人的段落，这个段落技术上是由在菲律宾的某人写的，但没写。就像他们必须输入它。他们必须输入那个人是谁，对吧？所以他们必须知道如何写。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。